clic clic waouh tu fais hyper bien le
clic merci à toi nouvelle émission de la
série dans son corps aujourd'hui c'est
eléonore qui vient nous parler de sa
maladie de peau
eléonore êtes atteints de dermatite
atopique depuis l'âge de trois mois elle
est actuellement reconversion
professionnelle à cause de sa maladie et
elle est bénévole au sein de l'aef de
l'association française de l'eczéma
eléonore bonjour d'engins quelle est la
particularité à toi j'ai une dermatite
atopique sévère c'est une maladie
inflammatoire de la peau mais aussi des
muqueuses tu le cuir chevelu et ça peut
attendre les yeux et toi tu as cette
maladie de cuisine
combien de temps ça a été diagnostiquée
vers l'âge de trois à quatre mois ok
donc pour ainsi dire ça tu as toujours
vêtu avec wes qui a eu du coup tu as
grandi avec
est ce que tu te souviens d'un moment où
tu as pris conscience que tu avais
quelque chose que les autres avaient pas
forcément
bah ouais en primaire déjà j'avais pas
mal des cuma mais je crois que c'est en
colonie de vacances
un jour je me suis levé pour prendre mon
petit déjeuner avec mes camarades et
quand je me suis installé à leur table
canal un caddie as tu des gouttes
et puis elle est partie j'ai dit ouais
je crois tu que tu est une particularité
la dermatite atopique qu'on appelle
aussi eczéma atopique c'est une maladie
inflammatoire qui provoque une rougeur
et une sécheresse de la peau et des
muqueuses avec des démangeaisons qui
peuvent être très forte et très
fréquentes
et ça peut toucher tout le corps elle
peut s'accompagner d'autres maladies
comme l'asthme ou des allergies
est ce que tu peux décrire un petit peu
ce que peut être une journée type en
période de crise de dermatite atopique
alors une journée type
je vais
remémorez l'année dernière dont j'étais
très attaquées au ciné au niveau des
yeux j'avais une information de la corne
est donc je voyais rien donc déjà sortir
du lit c'est compliqué parce que le fait
que particules tes bras ou est-ce que
c'est souvent aux pliures que ça se
passe donc ça va craquer ça va saigner
la douche c'est effroyable
ensuite il ya des soins parce qu'il ya
les soins oculaires et alléchant point
aussi parce que le cuir chevelu et
attaquer il faut désinfecter certaines
parties qui allie les crèmes après les
émollients il ya les médicaments aussi
ce qu'en pleine crise pour ma part
j'étais sous anxiolytiques pour gérer
maintenant voilà et puis en pleine crise
si je vais pas au travail bas je reste
chez moi enfin voila je me le fais mes
soins parce que c'est important et puis
souvent je retourne oeil je vais pas
sortir ou si je sors c'est parce que
j'ai rendez vous chez le médecin et ses
casquettes lunettes de soleil et si je
peux je prends un taxi pas savoir que
dans ces cas là ce qui rythme la vie
c'est pas vrai dit au fait oui en crise
oui et je veux voir personne
enfin mes proches parce qu'ils ne
connaissent pas ce que je vis mais sinon
je veux voir personne
la maladie n'a pas que des conséquences
physiques elle a aussi des répercussions
psychologiques sur le moral sur la vie
personnelle et affective des patients et
aussi des répercussions sociales et sur
la vie professionnelle le haut niveau d
symptôme à proprement parler et
c'est ça se manifestait comment chez toi
alors moi j'ai des allergies
environnementale j'ai des allergies
alimentaires
j'avais des conjonctivites à répétition
j'avais de l'eczéma qui s'injectaient
des staphylocoques l'herpès oculaire
herpès sur la peau donc voilà asthme au
niveau cutané
au niveau de la peau à proprement parler
c'était des poussées ou des crises qui
apparaît c'est qu'ils repartaient mouais
c'est chronique web donc ça dépend des
ça pouvait arriver n'importe quand je
pouvais me coucher il m'a réveillé le
lendemain et avoir d'eczéma sans savoir
d'où ça venait
et ça pouvait s'étaler sur des longues
sur de longues périodes
oui à la dernière a duré plusieurs mois
plusieurs mois et quand tu comptes est
en crise comme ça
e
j'ai entendu des patients raconté qu'ils
avaient même eu du mal à supporter en
fait c'était déjà fin tu dors très mal
parce que tu te gratter tu t'en rends
pas compte c'est inconscient tu te
réveilles tu as tes bras qui sont
tachées de sang faut que tu ailles
prendre sa douche melo c'est
insupportable en fait tu mets des crèmes
et comme ta peau est à vue bah ça ça
brûle de mettre les crèmes après tu
t'habilles donc 100% coton feinter
seuils de d'être le mieux possible mais
maintenant tout ça c'est pas trop
supportable donc ça veut dire que ce
soit en période de crise ou pas des
traitements quotidiens
ça veut dire qu'on va de crise un
inconfort une douleur
pratiquement pratiquement en continu le
plus le plus paisible à vivre dont tout
ça si tu devais sortir vraiment un truc
que le plus pénible ce serait quoi pour
soi en raison des bonnes raisons ouais
ouais tu te grattes jusqu'à que ça
saigne
parce que la démangeaison avait
tellement intense que tu préfères avoir
mal que cette envie de te démange et
ouais enfin moi c'est comme ça que je le
vis et plus grave plus à des bruits
ouais enfin moi je me grattais à 112
après les risques de surinfection web
assas infectés et ensuite dont tu as
grandi avec
cette maladie là donc je parlais du
regard des autres
à l'adolescence elle en france voilà il
ya peu de filtres mais avec les adultes
ça se passe ça se passe comment c'est
compliqué quand même
ouais c'est ça reste compliqué j'ai
travaillé très jeune j'ai fait un
apprentissage en pensant qu'en étant
dans un dans le monde du travail avec
des adultes ce serait différent mais
finalement c'est pareil c'est mérité
plus vicieux ouais forcément frontale
que bah ouais c'est ouais c'est
différent c'est quand qu'ils comptaient
tutu a des souvenirs un peu précis en
tête de deux situations où tu t'es dit
voilà c'est fait un record ouais bah je
crois que le pire
un mec avec qui je veux c'est qu'il m'a
regardé qui m'a dit t'es tu que tu as en
direct en phase terminale d'un cancer
ouais tu ne trouvons plus forcément ma
non c'est pas parce que tu es adulte que
tu es intelligent mais bon je suis tombé
sur des très bonnes personnes aussi un
pas parler il n'y a eu que des mauvaises
personnes mais j'en ai eu ouais j'en ai
pas mal
peut-être que tu as tu es sorti toute la
nuit c'était pas le cas
donc ouais il ya eu ça été une plieuse
est sale
la dermatite atopique à plusieurs formes
de la plus modérée à la plus sévère
c'est une maladie chronique c'est à dire
qu'on l'a toute sa vie mais heureusement
il ya des traitements par contre ça
n'est pas une maladie contagieuse
est-ce que tu as tu as senti par moments
ils ont pour être aussi méchant général
c'est qu'ils sont ont peur ce qu'ils ont
peur et qui savent pas forcément de quoi
de quoi est ce que tu as tu as senti
parfois jeu par la peur de la contagion
ah oui oui mais passons je disais
souvent on ne m inquiète c'est bon ça
s'attrape pas mais voilà quand tu dis
staphylocoques ou que tu dis virus les
gens ont quand même peur je crois que
c'est sur d'autres qui connaissent pas
en fait quand tu dis que tu as d'eczéma
souvent ça les stresse et c'est dans sa
tête
voilà mais en fait j'ai pas de l'eczéma
j'ai une dermatite atopique sévère donc
c'est pas pareil mais c'est pas une
maladie qui est vraiment connu mais
voilà tu as des gens qui viennent un
mais moi j'ai de l'eczéma sur le bout
des doigts j'ai mis de la crème et j'ai
pu rien qui ne soigne pas voilà je dis
rien parce que ça ne sert à rien de
toute façon il ya un moment donné je me
suis dit bon je vais je vais dire ce que
j'ai puis un jour il ya une nana qui m'a
dit tu en as marre d'être justifiée donc
j'ai dit bon c'est bon j'arrête je dis
plus rien ça sert à rien c'est perdu
d'avancé
voilà c'est dans ma tête ouais tu tues
et ouais c'est à lui qu'il est compliqué
à trouver entre faire de la pédagogie si
tu as envie d y était d'humeur et en
même temps pas toujours empreint de
temps at il expliqué elle file du mr
surtout ouais ouais c'est ça ton
parcours médical eux avec un peu
chaotique petit c'est ma mère qui gérait
dont ça allait plus ou moins à
l'adolescence j'étais rebelle et les
médecins ne les supportaient plus parce
que c'était toujours les mêmes
traitements et ça fonctionnait pas donc
je les envoyer chez donc j'ai arrêté
j'ai dit c'est bon je veux plus voir de
médecin
et puis je parte à l'étranger donc ça
allait beaucoup moins de problèmes et
puis quand je suis rentré je suis tombé
sur des très bons et un très bon
spécialiste qui ne suivent encore
aujourd'hui donc j'avais des traitements
j'avais un suivi
j'étais super bien encadré je les suis
encore aujourd'hui
ok bah oui parce que là je le vois comme
ça je devine à aucun moment que tu as
une dermatite atopique
c'est à dire que ces chroniques mais que
l'on il ya des coins des possibilités
pour que ça s'arrête sur les matériaux
de f1 sur les lèvres et les yeux par
exemple j'ai toujours eu d'accord parce
que c'était mon alimentation
puis vinrent les yeux j'ai toujours dit
un petit peu mais là j'ai un traitement
en fait qui fonctionne très bien depuis
plusieurs mois ok du coup sa valeur
depuis plusieurs mois j'ai plus rien
plus rien du tout j'ai même pas une
petite coupure j'ai pas une seule
démangeaisons je revis la dermatite
atopique touche plus de 2 millions de
personnes en france et la maladie de
peau la plus fréquente après la cne
pourtant de très nombreux patients ne
sont pas soigner efficacement et
connaissent des situations d'errance
thérapeutique le de ce que je comprends
de ce que tu me dis là comme assez
souvent dans ce genre de maladie ça
s'arrête
ou en tout cas ça mais ça s'améliore
vraiment le jour où tu tombes sur le
médecin qui un est un spécialiste de va
continuer à chercher ce qui te convient
tant qu' il n'a pas trouvé toi dans ton
parcours
est ce qu'il ya un jour quelqu'un c'est
à donner un conseil qui te dit quelque
chose qui t'a particulièrement marqué ou
est ce que toi d'un conseil à donner aux
gens qui peut-être les maladies de
de peau et qui savent pas trop comment
s'en sortir un jour j'y vais un dermato
que je vois plus aujourd'hui mais ce que
j'en ai fait pas mal qui m'a dit bon
soit que tu prends un traitement à
l'hôpital et tu vis maintenant ou soit
sûr est comme ça que tu vas livre à 60
ans parce que quand on vieillit on a
moins de problèmes ainsi voilà donc ça
c'est la première chose qui m'a dit ça
m'avait marqué je l'écouté et il m'avait
dit un peu de sport bonne nourriture du
repos une vie pas trop stressante est
inquiète pas ça va le faire
et voilà et je me suis dit elle n'a
peut-être pas tort bonne alimentation
une bonne hygiène de vie est donc le mal
que le le conseil ce serait bête de vie
ouais c'est important et est pas lâcher
enfin se soigner même si on a perdu même
si on en avoir mais ouais bah ouais
parce que moi aussi je suis passé par là
j'ai essayé donc des médecines
parallèles on va dire mais sympa
fonctionner j'essayais le mompati ce
qu'on n'a pas envie de prendre des
traitements qui sont un peu un peu fort
mais moi je suis tombé sur des médecins
en qui j'avais vraiment confiance et qui
me suivent depuis plusieurs années donc
je leur ai fait confiance et j'ai type
en bâtiment on y va et je regrette pas
aujourd'hui parce que j'ai plus rien
mais vous tomber sur le bon médecin
c'est ça et moi j'en ai fait plusieurs
voilà aujourd'hui j'ai des dermato je
fais partie d'une association est ce que
tu peux expliquer un petit peu salée
c'est l'association française d'eczéma
c'est mon médecin qui m'a dit de
rencontrer la fondatrice donc que je les
rencontre et à la journée nationale de
l'eczéma en juin dernier
donc j'ai rencontré pas mal de personnes
qui avaient la même pathologie et
déjà je me suis dit ok je suis pas tout
seul je suis pas folle on a les mêmes
symptômes parfois même le caractère et
voilà donc je fais des événements avec
elle des témoignages où je rencontre des
patients donc c'est ça permet d'assumer
un peu plus la maladie est le fait de
rencontrer des gens qui ont la même
chose que toi et qu'ils comprennent
ce que tu fais quelque chose d'important
ouais je pense que c'est très important
j'étais pas c'est un peu sceptique quoi
je me suis dit on en parlait que de ça
enfin j'ai pas envie puis finalement ça
m'a énormément aidé est-ce que tu as
l'impression que ce soit dans un rapport
au conseil que le dermato t'a donné à
savoir fait maintenant et tu vis
maintenant donc ce soit par rapport à
vous faites deux faire partie d'une
association où tu disais au départ j'ai
pas trop envie de parler comme ça et
c'est pour les deux gars c'est un petit
peu aussi dire des j'accepte toutes là
c'est ça en fait il faut assumer
moi j'ai toujours caché j'ai essayé de
cacher physiquement et part du
maquillage ou par des détenus par des
coupes de cheveux fins j'essayais de
faire diversion mais la maladie elle est
là donc il faut il faut l'accepter en
fait mais c'est compliqué d'accepter la
maladie étant donné qu'on prenait pas au
sérieux
ouais c'est un pad est à voir un petit
état des toc
j'ai fini par y voir un psy est ce que
je me suis dit en effet tout est dingue
mais non je ne suis pas mais je m'en
suis rendu compte là ya pas longtemps en
fait parce qu'avant je pensais que
j'étais dingue
bah oui parce que tous les messages
qu'on passait c'était était hyper
sensible mais tu es comme s'il était
comme ça non j'ai une dermatite atopique
sévère si tu si tu devais s'adresser à
quelqu'un qui peut-être un est dans ta
situation a dit à quelques quelques
années je suis en une phrase il passer
un message qu'est ce que tu as envie de
dieu m'a rejoint nouvelle association
rejoins-nous et puis on soutient quoi on
sert les coudes
merci beaucoup merci à toi
[Applaudissements]